avec nous ce soir l'un des porte paroles
les plus remarqués de cette coordination
nicole bénéfices l'école mais dévisse de
bonsoir alors vous avez décidé d'arrêter
la grève mais vous avez également
demandé aux syndicats de ne pas fini un
accord demain avec le ministre oui
effectivement ce que nous demandons aux
syndicats c'est ce qui me manquait a été
faite par motion on a demandé d'un
commun accord que les syndicats ne
signent pas sans que la base était été
consulté mais est-ce que vous ne perdez
pas en arrêtant la grève est ce que vous
ne perdez pas votre principal moyen de
pression à la fois sur les syndicats et
sur gouvernement non nous ne perdons
absolument pas notre moyen de pression
sur le gouvernement je crois que nous
restons déterminés l'importance
actuellement de la situation c'est que
le mouvement existe encore qu'il
persiste les infirmières sont déterminés
de toute façon à aboutir ce que nous
voulons maintenant et dans très
rapidement c'est que le gouvernement
enfin puisse nous entendre et que nous
puissions réellement établir un vrai
dialogue avec elle selon vous dites
déterminées pour vous la question
essentielle c'était le statut et non pas
les salaires or vous êtes arrêté là vous
vous arrêtez ce soir alors qu'est ce que
veut dire cette détermination quand on
s'arrête ainsi en plein milieu de leur
écurie il faut pas perdre de vue le fait
vivre on sait que ça fait déjà plus d'un
mois
pratiquement un mois que les infirmières
font la grève c'est très difficile pour
une infirmière de laine vous faire la
grève faut voir ce que ça représente sur
le terrain une infirmière qui fait la
grève une f1 qui fait la grève ça veut
dire qu'elle elle continue à travailler
elle continue à assurer les soins auprès
des malades
ça n'a rien à voir avec une autre
catégorie professionnelle dans un autre
secteur public ou autre je crois qu'une
infirmière a toujours eue a toujours su
prouver le son sens des responsabilités
face aux soins qu'elle prédit que malade
et vous pensez que donc le sort des
malades a été déterminant dans la
décision aujourd'hui d'arrêter la grève
non c'est pas le sort des malades qui
détermine ans je crois que les
infirmières ont besoin de se ressaisir
aujourd'hui ce vieux oui de se ressaisir
pour essayer de trouver une nouvelle
forme de grève parce que c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile pour les
infirmières de la base puisqu'elles ont
assuré un service minimum depuis depuis
le début de ce conflit
nous ce qu'on souhaite aujourd'hui c'est
que le gouvernement arrête de d'avoir
cette attitude de fermeture à notre
égard il faut qu'ils prennent conscience
que il se passe un grave problème à la
santé et qu' il est temps qu'ils
réagissent et qu'on arrête de nous
considérer comme comme un mouvement de
deux femmes
énervé comme un mouvement de femmes qui
sont incapables de se gérer je crois que
nous avons fait un mouvement que nous
avons prouvé qu'un mouvement exemplaires
je crois que le gouvernement doit être
capable de nous écouter aujourd'hui nous
lui disons quand allez vous enfin ouvrir
vos portes à la coordination pour en
fait vous avez n'ai pas peur j'attends
d'être doublé par la cgt là parce que je
vois poursuite qu'en ce qui concerne la
cgt poursuite du mouvement y compris par
la grève parce que d'un côté donc quatre
ou cinq syndicats qui risque de signer
demain d'un autre côté la cgt qui veut
maintenir éventuellement la grève
et vous qui n'existaient pas
institutionnellement avec quoi vous
allez vous allez pouvoir vous battre
parce qu'après tout vous n'existez pas
je veux dire juridiquement effectivement
juridiquement nous n'existons pas c'est
un débat qui est en train de naître
intérieur de la coordination sein de la
coordination
il est effective pour avoir une
représentativité juridique il faut avoir
il faut déposer un label un statut bon
c'est une discussion de fond qui existe
à l'heure actuelle au sein du bureau de
la coordination nationale
quoi qu'il en soit nous avons su montrer
aux pouvoirs publics la force que nous
représentions et donc vous avez
l'intention de continuer à vous battre
nous avons l'intention et la ferme
détermination de le faire à n'importe
quel moment nous sont prêtes pour
repartir
l'école bénéfices merci